hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong the podcast
where we take a movie look at that
tomato meter score and say that maybe
that's a little too high that's way too
low or it's just right my name is mark
ellis my co-host as always jacqueline
coley is on a much deserved vacation
again she's kind of in between that like
covering awards season and then going to
film festival season so she gets just a
little crevice being a a cover of movies
the scope and breadth of which
jacqueline coley achieves is kind of
like being a college football coach
there may be an offseason in theory
there never is as soon as you you win in
the playoff you got to go right back to
recruiting for the next season so that's
what jacqueline's taking care of me
meanwhile setting up some stand-up dates
for the fall including atlanta la jolla
new orleans possibly is going to be on
the docket so new york is obviously
always there let me know what other
cities you want to come have me come to
but right now today it's all about one
of the more i'd say divisive movies of
the last decade some people love it some
people hate what they did to their
beloved band and some folks are just meh
about bohemian rhapsody the queen biopic
from 2018 that is currently 60
on the tomato meter which means it's
fresh and that's the lowest possible
number it could be and still be fresh so
it is right there on the mendoza line
the audience score is much improved 85
for that one so i have two very special
guests that we're going to be debating
back and forth whether we think rotten
tomatoes the tomato meter got it right
with bohemian rhapsody this film was
recommended to us by a cacophony of fans
as you will rafael terrazza sean cahey
and ck anderson thank you so much
raphael had some great thoughts about
queen the band and so i want to read
some of those here before we get going
queen was known to be bold fearless and
innovative i will die on the sword that
had this movie been rated r the movie
could have matched the band's ambition
by giving us an authentic look into the
members lives especially freddy's think
about it this way how can a movie about
a guy who had no filter and used to
swear like a sailor be rated pg-13
that's a great point raphael so we're
going to talk about maybe whether the
movie should have been r-rated maybe
they should have pushed the envelope a
little farther but we're not there yet
where we are is introducing my
incredible guests today we got two of
them because lord knows i can't steer
this ship by myself first up is a
wonderful correspondent for everything
from rotten tomatoes to fandango you see
her on morning tv all the time oscar's
red carpet and
amateur rattlesnake wrangler as i just
found out is nikki novak nikki it is
such a pleasure to see you and join you
once again
and i am here i am here like you said i
am a part-time rattlesnake wrangler not
by choice just i live in an area where
there are a lot of rattlesnakes we were
talking about that before we started
rolling but that's a whole other episode
how are you
you survived and and i am terrified of
snakes if you think indiana jones
doesn't like his snakes just come on
over to uh old mark ellis's place
terrified of them love them to death
fascinated by them but cannot deal with
them unfortunately today is not anaconda
it is bohemian rhapsody so while we have
myself and nikki here i'm also going to
introduce our other very special guest
who you know from the hit youtube series
pay or wait a critic across the board
certified with all of the things that
you need to be to be one of the top
critics in the world and that is
sharonda williams hello sharonda it is
so good you and i have been live on
stage together we've done this show
before what's new with you you know i'm
just surviving actually i started my
fitness journey i am one of those people
who get excited to work out i have
become my worst nightmare and i'm kind
of here for it but you said started your
fitness journey so do you think you'll
still be excited to work out
in say a couple months i don't know
my body has been breaking down each day
i've i've gotten aches and pains in my
knees so let's hope that we can stay on
the right path forward okay let's just
hope that this sticks hey i'm i'm proud
of you i'm proud of both y'all for
taking the time out i know you all have
busy lives and schedules and a lot of
success going on in your individual
career so thanks for gracing our show
and myself with your presence so let's
go ahead and talk about this right now
just a quick synopsis about bohemian
rhapsody it is based on the story of the
band queen particularly the lead singer
freddie mercury but we also get into
some brian may some roger taylor and
some other founding members of the band
but also their management behind the
scenes what's going on their touring
years everything leading up from the
formation of the group to their heroic
performance at 1985's live aid and when
we look at the movie and the tomato
meter i'll start with you sharonda 60
is what rotten tomatoes has to say about
the film do you think that rotten
tomatoes is wrong about that score for
bohemian rhapsody i think they're riding
tomatoes is not only wrong but highly
disrespectful i just don't understand
why there is so much hate against this
movie does anyone have hearts out there
what is happening i mean sometimes the
movie needs a friend and it seems like
to quote freddie himself you might be
the best friend of this movie
see if nicki feels the same way nikki is
rotten tomatoes wrong with that 60
rotten tomatoes is wrong but not in the
sense that you're thinking because i
think this is the only movie in the
history of movies that should have two
rotten tomatoes scores they should have
one score for the first hour and 53
minutes of the film and another score
for the last 13 and a half minutes
because they are two totally different
movies in my opinion and should have
vastly different scores that is very
fair we're going to talk about what
maybe what scene we're talking where
nikki's referencing when she says that
tomato meter might kick up a little bit
towards the end of the film um i think
that rotten tomatoes is wrong about the
60 percent i don't think they're dead
wrong i think that
it's really tough because as we talk
about this the behind the scenes the
movie we got if i'm just judging it as a
film i think it's fresh and i think it
deserves to be above that 60 percent
into the 70s or 80s but when you look at
some of the facts that may have been
skewed that might have been sugar coated
that might have just been flat out wrong
it's hard to say so maybe the bigger fan
of queen you are maybe you just can't
celebrate this or maybe just love seeing
your favorite band on the big screen so
let's get into all of this but first we
always go to our expert review curation
manager tim ryan who takes all those
critic reviews at the time of the film's
release and condenses it into a segment
we like to call two minutes with tim
let's hit it
as an artist and as a person freddie
mercury defied convention and easy
categorization and movie biopics are
notorious for following a strict formula
even for the most fascinating of
subjects that was an issue critics had
with bohemian rhapsody while rami melik
won praise for his performance there was
a large contingent that felt the movie
as a whole was a little by the book
though virtually everyone agreed the
music was pretty rockin
bohemian rhapsody is fresh at 60 on the
tomato meter with 415 reviews but it
does have an 85 percent audience score
this was definitely a case of the
audience embracing the movie whatever
its faults
so what did the critics have to say in a
fresh review chris knight of canada's
national post wrote the biopic treatment
is not the equal of its subject but it
is still a well-made and loving tribute
that will send you scurrying to dig out
your old queen lps to remember what all
the fuss was about however in a rotten
review david lambeau of the bay area
reporter wrote as a biopic bohemian
rhapsody falls short failing to
adequately examine mercury's life and
the people in it
malek who put so much effort into
bringing mercury to life and who gives
such a brilliant performance deserves
better as does the audience
the rotten tomatoes critics consensus
reads bohemian rhapsody hits a handful
of high notes but has an in-depth look
at a beloved band it offers more of a
medley than a true greatest hits
collection so that's bohemian rhapsody
let's kick it back to mark he's having
such a good time he's having a ball
don't
stop him now
back to you tim i thought i told you i
want to ride my bicycle i want to ride
my bike you know before we kick it
straight to movie talk we should
probably bring in producie lucy our own
lead singer of the show lucy you have
an incredible vocal range very much like
freddie mercury himself
what did you wish of bohemian rhapsody
so last night was the first time
i saw the film to celebrate before i saw
the film i actually went to karaoke to
get into the spirit
of freddie
i didn't sing any queen but i should
have
so
i went in so queen huge part of my
childhood my parents gave this movie to
me
gave this movie gave the this band to me
um introduced me to it and
i fell in love when i was like i don't
know six or seven
this music was what we listened to on
road trips my dad instilled the like
head banging like from wayne is that
wayne's world
yeah you know bohomian rhapsody headbang
love this band uh this m this movie
bohemian rhapsody
made me actually love queen's music a
little less
wow
i really i they just skipped over i mean
i just didn't to nicki's point the first
hour and 50 minutes
it just felt like they were just
shooting across all these things i don't
know much about the band's backstory and
i still don't know i just i feel like
they really glossed over things and i
was i was amazed by the fact that the
filmmakers somehow managed to stretch
out this long
movie and yet tell me nothing well
possibly the key word there being
filmmakers and not just filmmakers so
that's the perfect segue into our movie
talk segment brian do we have music for
that
i knew the answer already so
we're going to talk about the film here
with sharonda and nikki and myself and i
just want to stress that there was a lot
of behind-the-scenes drama there was a
switching of director pretty much
halfway through the movie there was a
lot of editing difficulty in that
switcheroo so
but if we take all of that and put it on
the back burner for now and we just look
at the movie itself nikki the first time
you saw this movie
did you have that thought that you do
now that like ah the first almost two
hours ed the last part great or did you
walk out of the theater and then you
just kind of revision this history like
now that i have some time to chew on
this i feel differently well let me
first say that i didn't think the first
hour and 50 minutes were uh i just felt
like they were two totally different
movies okay because one took a lot of
liberties with the truth and with
factual you know there's been plenty of
articles and brian may has talked about
the factual inaccuracies of the movie
that he approved of because he's like
this is how we wanted to tell the story
which i totally understand but then you
go from that to this
to this 13-minute live aid performance
that is a shot for shot nuance to nuance
blink to blink
side-by-side comparison to the actual
performance so you went from taking so
many liberties to then going so
factually accurate that it and it was
shot in a different way it had a
different feel it had a different style
that it felt like two different movies i
was uh about parts of it but to answer
your question the first time i saw i
covered the junket for this and just to
sort of give some people an idea of how
i experienced this movie for the first
time this was one of those films and
this happens sometimes with marvel
movies when you cover the junker where
they don't show you the whole movie
before you do your interviews so what
happened was we all all the press went
down to fox to 20th century fox
lot
in the morning they showed us 45 minutes
of the film but they didn't show us like
the first 45 minutes where then they
leave you hanging and you're like what
happens next
they showed us sort of a synopsis of the
whole film jammed into 45 minutes so i
didn't get to experience the whole movie
as a first-time viewer if that makes
sense so i saw snippets of it
then
they had us all drive out to this
airport hangar where we boarded like a
747 with rami malik with the entire cast
and jumped on a flight with them to
vegas so we were treated like rock stars
we had the junket that afternoon but
they also had all these activities for
us likely we got a guitar lesson where
we got to learn how to like play a queen
song they gave us like
jackets like jean jackets that we got to
like bedazzle ourselves they treated us
so well and as you all i'm sure know if
you've talked to rami malik or you
haven't he's so lovable and he's just
you know he's so personable
and we were some of the first people to
see the footage so the first time i saw
the film i saw this truncated version of
it
and based on that i was like
first of all and the other thing is i
saw footage of ramy malik the year
before at cinemacon and called that he
was going to win best actor a year
before patting myself on the back for
that one but
i said to myself after seeing the
footage this is not a best picture
nominee
this is a popcorn movie this is a fun
movie
and what i appreciate about i've now
seen it i think four or five times
and the first time i saw that smaller
version of it i was like this is fun
it's not what i expected i expected it
to be this gritty sort of oscar bait
type movie that's not what it was
then i saw the whole movie
but it's funny because i hadn't watched
the movie since probably 2019 and i
watched it two nights ago
and i swear i checked my i paused the
movie a couple times to go did i skip
over a couple scenes
am i missing like i don't remember them
telling the story like this way where
it's jumping from thing to thing to
thing and it felt like an overview it
felt to me like i was missing something
like that's where they jumped in the
store it was a different movie than i
remembered
and i will end on saying this
while
i understand
that this was not the movie a lot of
queen fans were hoping for in terms of
grittiness and really going there and
being r-rated the fact that my
11-year-old nephew
who previous to prior to bohemian
rhapsody only cared about marvel
was obsessed with queen and knows every
queen album now
told me that that sometimes the actual
like that to me is more important
than perhaps doing this little smaller
indie gritty movie that maybe would have
had more academy award
you know i mean it did win four awards
that to me is as important as
i think they got it right and i think
roger taylor or roger yeah roger taylor
has said
you know this is a movie that freddy
would have wanted this movie to
entertain and it did that it did
entertain yeah it's it's it's a fair
synopsis i guess sharonda to say that
this maybe is the more kid-friendly
queen movie where this is a film made to
please all fans of queen and introduce
new generations like nikki's nephew to
queen and so wait when i saw this movie
i walked out of the theater shironda and
i said two things right away i need to
go youtube live aid because i want to
watch the original one i was so pumped
up from the end of the movie where we
see live aid but also that rami malik is
at least a shoe-in to get nominated and
i might have even thought that from
watching the trailer what were your
thoughts when you left that theater the
first time you saw bohemian rhapsody
sharonda it's a lot of the same thoughts
that you know both of you have said i
mean for me i never
have that much faith in biopics because
hollywood or even those that are
involved whose story this revolves
around they're never gonna let you fully
tell the truth they're not gonna let you
tell those dirty little secrets that
everyone's talked about you're not gonna
be able to see that type of those type
of things on screen but for a good
biopic to me
is something that reminds you of why you
love queen
why you enjoy their music and it's
something that after you walk out of
that theater you want to know even more
and for me i wasn't the hugest like
queen fan don't don't kill me but
i knew the highlights like i knew the
sounds when i was watching i was like oh
my goodness that was did this song but
after i walked out i went and watched
the live aid
um footage and then for the next week i
watched every single freddy mercury
documentary queen documentary listen to
all of the songs like that is what a
good biopic does it's not meant to be
like a word for word like this is what
happened in that person's life but it's
something to give you the highlights to
get you excited to help you understand
this is why people love queen this is
why people love freddie mercury and this
is why we continue we need to continue
to really just spread the word of who
these icons are and i feel like for the
movie it did that especially given if
you read into the backstory of
everything that happened honestly it's a
it's a shock that this movie was even
made that it was even brought to screen
for us to actually be able to watch so i
think that's a triumph in itself so
that's why i have a question
i want to know if there's anybody out
there who has ever watched this movie no
matter how many times you've watched it
and not gone back to the live aid on
youtube afterwards if there's anybody
that has been able to do that i want to
i want to hear from you and how you were
able to do that because i even the other
night went down a rabbit hole and
started watching all the stuff all over
again and and and we're saying i mean it
builds up fandoms even if you've never
heard a queen before or if if they just
weren't in your real lexicon they
weren't one of your favorite bands i
think it does up their status in
everybody's you know catalog but shirana
makes a great point where i think that
especially where we are now in society
look i i do a joke now in my act about
documentaries where it's like can we
maybe just have a one-part documentary
again because documentaries have now
become 10 parts and so i think that even
our minds separating a film from a
documentary if it's a biopic we're like
well where's the next chapter where's
the next this why didn't they get as
deep as they could and it's because it's
just a movie it's it's only two hours
and so we do have to do a sugary
glossing of some of these things and the
fact that the band was so intricately
involved in making this movie sort of
reminded me of straight out of compton
because you had particularly it with
that film you had dr dre and ice cube
who were key behind the scenes members
of making that movie that's a lot higher
on the tomato meter some facts probably
massaged or skewed in both of these film
you know examples
but the thing that brian and i saw this
from brian may the guitarist to queen
was quoted as saying like they wanted to
show how important freddie was not just
to the band but to the culture and so
when we talk about this movie romney
malek's performance
i not only think it was worthy of
winning the oscar that year it's just to
see him completely become freddie
mercury
it was just it was a revelation to
behold and i think that sometimes a
performance like that can elevate the
overall feeling we have about a movie
i mean we can argue about whether or not
he should have won the oscar because
that was a big year i'm sorry we had
bradley cooper for a star is born that
had my heart that year i was a little
heartbroken he didn't win but rami's
performance
if you do go on youtube after and you
start watching freddie mercury
interviews because i actually went and
watched now if you've seen it the live
aid interview they did before they went
on stage
and he was very chill like he wasn't
there were there were moments and i know
that freddy when he talked had that
mouth you know he would do that thing
with his mouth that rami did throughout
the movie that i think rami is still
doing to a certain degree
even years later
but
rami's performance wasn't always i mean
in the alive aid it was exact and there
were moments in the film where he was
very much like freddie mercury but there
were a lot of moments that i feel like
he amped it he was almost and i don't
want to use the word cartoonish but
slightly like he slightly over played
like freddie sometimes just sat back in
interviews and was just like cool like
he was a cool guy and he was very
articulate
but i feel like
the fact that rami and i say cartoonish
in a as a compliment because he went so
big and bold in his choices it made its
mark right like
it is so it's so indelible with that
film like that he made those choices and
i know sasha baron cohen was talked
about maybe he was going to play you
know the the freddie mercury character
in its earlier iterations and when you
look at sacha baron coin you go oh my
gosh he looks exactly like freddie
mercury
but i don't think
the energy
that he that rami brought that
incredible energy that you saw in
freddy's performances was spot on yeah
so sharonda if i'm sort of going to give
nikki the the uh the live aids scene as
far as like if we're talking about our
favorite scenes in the movie what do you
kind of look at besides the live aid
closing of the film as like that's
that's why i that's why i really like
this movie what was the scene
that was the most memorable for you
besides live aid i think for me and
going piggybacking off of rami's
performance
a good performance to me is not just how
you look and not how you talk but it's
really like the the error that you have
and there is like a confidence that
romney really exuded that even when he
wasn't talking like you felt like felt
like it was freddy like you feel like it
was this person that was really ahead of
the times ahead of you know their era
and it was a few scenes it's really when
he interacts with lucy
um if you look at in the fitting room
where you know he gravitates towards
clothes but it's on the the women's rack
but he didn't realize it and even how
you just see how he looks at himself in
the mirror like this is totally normal
and i feel confident and i don't care
like what anyone else has to say and
even when he first meets the band
members
you know it's those little like looks
that he has how he holds his head up
high when someone says when they make
fun of his teeth and he holds his head
up high is those like quiet moments
those little mannerisms that rami does
like those are the moments that actually
stick with me even outside of the live
aid performance also um
write songs
might be of interest to you
it's just a bit of fun really you're
five minutes too late
our lead singer just quit
well then you'll need someone new
any ideas
what about me
uh
not with those teeth mate
and it's that defiance too that that
freddie had a streak of and so i i'm
always accused of this and it's true
when we talk about comic book films my
favorite ones are the origin story of
the superhero once we get into all the
sequels and now multiverses it's like
all right cool i like seeing how the
hero became a superhero i like seeing
how an ordinary person became a saver of
the universe so with bohemian rhapsody i
love their first performance together
because they're playing one of my
favorite queen songs which is keep
yourself alive and they're going through
it and freddie's kind of like changing
the words on them and they're like what
the hell is this guy what have we just
gotten ourselves into but it's like a
cat falling down the stairs they land on
their feet and that's what happened and
so that's what i love about this movie
is that it gives me that feeling but the
criticism that i would have is that like
i don't know if that's exactly how it
went i don't know if later on in the
film we get a studio creation of another
one bites to dust where the band is just
feels like they're on their last legs
and they're in an argument then all of a
sudden i think it's john deacon just
starts doing the the bass and it's like
wait a minute what's that that's a hit
song and it's like is that really it
really came together that easy but it it
makes you feel like you love queen even
more and so that's the achievement of
the film
is there a scene for you nikki where
you're like wait a minute this is this
is what i'm talking about this is why
this feels like a totally different
movie than the thing i love at the end
you mean in the in the terms of like not
not being as good as it could have been
yeah yeah well it
i would say i know a lot of people sort
of made fun of that one scene that
because the editor won for best editing
at the oscars and there was the one
scene where they're meeting the was it
where they're meeting the man is it the
manager that they're yeah and there was
all those quick cuts and he's even said
if i could recut that scene i would
recut that scene
um but it's not so much one scene to me
it's little moments like for example
and i'm gonna go back to the live aid
but
you know in the live aid performance if
you do there's a youtube video where
there's a shot by shot side by side
and they cut to the band a lot which i
in the actual film where they don't do
it in the live they usually show freddie
close up and then show the band more in
a wide shot and i understand for
dramatic purposes why they did it but
there's something in acting called
indicating when you indicate your
feelings to something rather than just
letting trusting that the audience if
you don't put it on your face the
audience will see it and i think this is
a choice by queen but they showed the
band going hey like smile like hey they
really like us like kind of like and if
you actually watch the performance
they're not going doing that they're
cool you know they're performing they're
not like looking at each other they're
going hey can you believe a hundred
thousand people like us like that to me
are the things like the cheesiness that
you didn't need to do
but when you hear queen talk about it
later they do talk about the fact that
they they felt that energy swell because
this is considered to be the best you
know the greatest live performance of
all time they weren't expecting the
audience reaction that they got even
though they were huge stars
but i don't think they needed to
indicate that as much as they did so
little things like that sort of got
under my skin where they didn't need to
show us so much like trust your audience
a little bit more there was a shredder
there was a lot of um you know people
griping which i understand about the
film not getting as deep as it as it
should have in a lot of people's eyes
into freddie mercury's sexuality and and
his expression um
do you feel like the movie sure changed
it because i remember like the movie
will drop will drop hints from time to
time and it certainly suggests a lot of
it and and who he is as a person but
is that one of those storylines that you
think maybe we should have gone more
than skin deep with i mean yeah i mean i
agree yes
but i never for once thought that they
were gonna delve deep into that because
it's hollywood and we already know how
the pandering goes to the community and
it's something that should have happened
yes
but where were you gonna fit that in i
felt like they could have delved even
deeper into the other band members but
once again like how do you
how do you take this entire career clean
and then take the entire just personal
lives of all these members and fit it
into a two-hour movie like it it's just
not possible it's not physically
possible for them to encompass
everything i do think that that's a big
part of who freddie was and i think that
that would delve even more into just
like that internal battle you know of
what freddie was going through but also
to how once again freddie was ahead of
the times and really understanding where
the world was at that point in time and
freddie deciding to actually be
you know a rule breaker and to actually
do you know what freddie wants to do
but i mean yes but i never expected them
to give a justice from in the first
place yeah i mean and i'll give the
other band members their flowers the
actors that play them because you have
guillem lee as brian may who i thought
was fanta i mean you want to talk about
doing a dead-on brian may impression
that guy knocked it out of the park and
there's a lot of interesting aspects of
brian may's life as well because post
queen he got his like doctorate he's
like one of the the leading
astrophysicists in the entire world and
oh by the way he's one of the greatest
guitar players ever lived you got ben
hardy who played roger taylor and then
john deacon um was
played by joe mazzello is the guy's name
and lucy boyden was great as mayor in
the film too so you know there's a lot
of moving parts here and and as you sort
of peel back the layers of what went on
behind the scenes you had brian singer
who was the original director who shot
the bulk of the movie and then there's a
whole lot going that's a whole other
podcast with that firestorm that was
happening and then he gets ousted
because there's multiple reports of hi
of friction to say the least on set as a
you know the all the other things that
brian um the you know brian singer had
his allegations that came out after the
fact and then dexter fletcher steps in
dexter fletcher who has gone on to do
rocket man with taran egerton and that
movie is super fresh as well so dexter
flesher comes in he's like okay how can
i piece this together nikki to your
point with the editing i think that
the editing in this film is both the
high achievement of editing and it's
also there's a couple scenes where it's
like we don't have the footage to make
this movie the way that we're trying to
so we just have to kind of
ping pong around the story and the
conversations but just the fact that we
could cobble a film together i think is
worthy of the nomination that the
editors got for this film but i mean
there are some rough moments in the
movie i will get i will say that they
want editing for the live a performance
like that's that was the only scene that
was watched that's why they won and i
feel like everyone just needs to make
peace with this
i love that you pointed that out too
because john ottman is the guy who was
who was the lead editor and john ottman
also
um is a composer and also and is a great
musician and he did a lot of the the
music for brian singer's previous film
so nikki maybe he did have a little
intuition particularly about those live
performance scenes and the editor has
talked about the fact that when you know
directors switched hands
that there were certain things that
dexter fletcher had to go in and shoot i
like i think that that scene that he
people made fun of him for wasn't added
on scene because narratively they
changed the story a little bit so it was
cobbled together very last minute it
wasn't part of the original narrative so
and he also said something interesting
that a lot of times when he is editing a
film he's getting footage like daily and
he's putting the film together daily he
said he didn't get all this footage
until it was in the can so he was
starting it after the fact after it was
all sort of done and that's a different
beast than when you're getting something
throughout and you're getting the
director's notes throughout and you're
sort of working in collaboration i mean
the fact that you know there was
reportedly so much friction between
brian singer and rami malik just going
back to that the fact that rami pulled
that performance out like romney's never
spoken exactly
what his gripe was with brian i know
there was reports that he wasn't showing
up for a director to be fired with three
weeks left to go on a film
something
went down like so the fact that they put
this film together the way they did and
romney
that performance came out
despite what was going on behind the
scenes is a huge testament
to his focus and his passion but you
felt it like what sharonda was saying
about rami had a next level energy and
the next level passion about this and
you felt that energy within the
performance he channeled it queen is one
of those rare bands that has had a few
different resurgences over the years
obviously they were arguably the biggest
rock band in the world at their peak and
then the 80s
create these sort of sports arena
anthems and we will rock you is at the
top of every one of those lists and then
the 90s come around and we get a little
movie called wayne's world and they're
all head-banging to bohemian rhapsody
and one of the things that i love but i
would i really want sharonda nicki's
opinion on this because i've argued with
some of my best friends about whether
this was a distraction from the film was
ray foster who was an emi executive when
queen was on their way to the top
played by mike myers in this movie and
mike myers is having a ball clearly
playing sort of against type wayne
campbell would hate this guy because
rey's the one who says we can't put
bohemian rhapsody on the we can't
release it as a single no teenagers are
ever going to head bang to bohemian
rhapsody which is a very obvious winking
nod to wayne's world i thought it was
really fun to have mike myers playing
that guy and i thought he did a great
job sharonda
am i crazy here
no i totally loved it it was a huge
night to everyone who watches wayne's
world and also too
for those kids who need their little
history given to them you know they're
gonna hear people chuckled in the
theater and they're gonna be like i
don't understand like what's so funny
and then you go home you show them the
clip and now they can go down a whole
other rubber hole of things that we fell
in love with growing up so i thought it
was great i thought it was fun and it
was really great to see him to be a part
of it and know like how he put people on
to like doing this to bohemian rhapsody
i thought i thought it was very clever
yeah and nikki you got to feel like part
of that because the band itself the
surviving members had so much to do with
the making of this movie you feel like
that was them saying thank you to mike
myers for putting bohemian rhapsody it
was back at number one on the charts in
the early 90s because of wayne's world i
think that scene in that office is one
of the greatest scenes like as a critic
you can look at this movie and go
whether the tomatoes score works or not
but as an entertaining film that you go
back and you that was iconic
scaramouche like the way he said i'm
doing a terrible mike myers impression
but the way he says scaramouche
scaramouche but it was also fascinating
because how i don't know how
historically factual that actual scene
was but when you hear
through the lens of this guy going
like nobody wants to listen to a rock
opera and you sort of realize the odds
that they were working against and the
fact that and somebody said this in a
comment about the film and about
watching freddie mercury certain artists
perform to impress freddie mercury
performed to express
to express himself and the fact that he
had that much conviction in himself to
walk out of that guy's office and go you
will be forever known as the guy that
you know turned down queen
brilliant like mike drop i loved that
scene i thought mike myers was amazing
all kinds of amazing
you will forever be known as the man who
lost queen
temperamental artists say they're well
aware they're tied to a contract but who
knows what goes on inside the
inscrutable mind of the recording these
words if they're not careful by the end
of the year
no one will know the name queen
christ
you can take that out of our royalties
and it's inspiring i think whether you
care about queen or regardless of where
you are in your life you see is somebody
who believes in themself and their
creations that much i think it does put
a little juice and a little bit of pep
in your step fun fact is that the studio
see it's always studious we always play
we we never thank studios for making
great movies we always just blame them
for meddling like in wayne's world the
studio kept kept pushing for them to
have a guns n roses song i i think they
just wanted welcome to the jungle in
there in that opening scene in wayne's
world and mike myers just much like
freddie mercury fighting for
representation with emi mike myers is
like no it's got to be bohemian rhapsody
i promise it's going to work and i'd say
it worked out okay for the movie for the
band for everyone in between my biggest
gripe with this film and the way that it
tells the story is that i'm fine with
sugar coating i'm fine with hinting at
things where maybe a documentary would
show us more layers but it's a real
bummer
to have two facts so severely distorted
that it does take the movie down a peg
for me i can still give it a fresh
rating like sharonda but it like freddie
mercury going out wanting to make a solo
album when roger taylor had already done
a couple i don't know how the band felt
about all that stuff but there's no
clear historical record that anyone
including freddie mercury himself was
aware that he had contracted the hiv
virus before 1987 and in the film it's
sort of made to look like hey we got
this one last hurrah at live aid knowing
what we know and it just felt like that
was a bridge too far
for me knowing that i'll start with you
sharonda does that take the movie down a
peg for you that it takes some of the
facts and doesn't just distort them it
really felt like it changed some band
history i know i sound like a broken
record but this is just what they do in
these movies i mean i think for die hard
like queen fans or just even people who
just want to make sure that things are
historically accurate like i definitely
see how people could be upset by it but
for
a biopic they're going for the
heartstrings what is going to tell a
deeper more impactful story to make
people you know
really understand
more about this figure and i
that's that's that's what these studios
do they meddle they mess with stuff they
try to pull at your heartstrings and
sometimes it doesn't go over well with
everyone and nikki it is tugging at the
heartstrings even more with that wive
aide scene as we set up for because we
feel it i almost felt like my my heart
strings were being a little manipulated
there well you know and this is what's
interesting is is they have the the band
queen who collaborated have said they
wanted to end the film on
on the live a performance they didn't
want to go any further in the story so
what could they have done if they he
hadn't announced to his bandmates in the
film his hiv diagnosis and then they end
up
you know with his high note they could
have maybe put it in print afterwards
you know two years after this live aid
performance
but here's the thing i don't think it
was necessary to sort of build things
into the story for dramatic effects the
band had enough drama like i don't think
you needed that i don't think you needed
the other thing that wasn't historically
accurate was that they hadn't played
together in years and what i didn't like
about the film was when the two days
before the performance freddie's like
he can't sing they haven't played
together in years that wasn't true they
had been playing together consistently i
think they had released an album don't
get don't fact check me on this if i'm
wrong but i think they released an album
the year before they were consistently
performing together so this idea that
they hadn't played together in years and
wasn't gonna work and then all of a
sudden they walk on stage and it's magic
like i think um may has talked about the
fact that freddie was tight like he was
not
you know fighting against the odds to
make sure his voice was okay for this
performance he was okay throughout so
but i don't think you needed any of
these things for dramatic effect i don't
think you needed him to announce to the
band ahead of time i don't think you
needed a lot of the stuff that they
added in to create this sort of dramatic
art in the film i think they could have
worked off of what was real and found
enough dramatic beats that's the thing
about us fans is is we want our cake and
we want to eat it too we want you to get
deeper with all these historical facts
but we also want them to be presented
accurately and so sometimes especially
again given what we just covered with
the behind-the-scenes making of this
movie you gotta think everyone involved
in the film is like look we did our best
do you like queen or not go enjoy the
movie and also give a nod to this scene
that i don't think gets talked about
enough because it's such a quick thing
you could blink and miss it or go to the
bathroom and you'd have no idea what
happened but it's freddy walking out of
a meeting with his doctor um you know
sort of getting an update on on his
vitals and and as he's walking out
there's another young man who is waiting
to go in and and it's clear by the
indications of the movie in the film is
that you have this guy who's also hiv
positive and that was becoming the aids
epidemic at the time in the in the mid
to late 80s and the fan kind of looks
and he doesn't know it's freddie murphy
right off the bat but he's like that
that kind of looks like freddie mercury
freddie's walking out and he's almost
about to the doors to clear it but he
stops and just gives him a little
freddie mercury head on and it's just
like you just get chills thinking about
how much they meant to fans and how much
freddie mercury meant to to the gay
community because he was this person who
was so out there and was and was so at
the top of his game for so long i would
put you know him in the same category as
as magic johnson it's like when you have
celebrities like that who battle
something like this so uh what ended up
being a public battle for freddie
although is private for most of it i
think that that does place a priority on
the rest of the world to say we need to
do something about this and i think a
lot of dollars were contributed to aids
research because of freddie mercury and
then obviously with magic johnson too so
as we kind of put a button on this
conversation we've gone to a lot of
different paths and that's why i love
having shironda nikki on the show let's
talk about the best musical biopics of
all time uh sharonda we've been kind of
kicking around how sometimes doesn't
matter how accurate of a musical biopic
it is there's going to be some things
that weren't necessarily true to history
but we need it for the film so what
would you say is your favorite musical
biopic of all time and then where does
bohemian rhapsody rank in there okay i'm
going off a childhood okay so bear with
me and i have to break this up into tv
and movie so
my tv the jackson five story i watched
this movie every single time it came on
vh1 i will stop what i'm doing i will
watch that movie i can quote it still
can't moonwalk but i know how to
visually see it in my head i can't do it
physically it's okay but also too
since we're talking about the disrespect
that i want to bring this back to
what's love got to do with it and the
fact that angela bassett did not win for
that movie it still hurts it still hurts
me
but i really i feel like that is
actually one of the biopics that
actually got into
the nitty-gritty
that really like delved deeper than our
what i think that most people would have
thought that they would have covered i
think if anyone wants to see like how do
you actually like tell a story and still
keep people invested while still being
honest to the story i feel like what
love got to do with it that's that's my
movie right there and you picked a
winner because i wholeheartedly agree
there was no other performance better
than angela bassett that year and it's
96 percent on the tomato meter so nikki
that's a high bar to pass is 96 for
musical biopic what would be the one you
point to and you say that that's how you
make a biopic in the world of music
first i want to say that i can moonwalk
i was a michael jackson fan as well well
yeah i have a glitter glove if you see a
rattlesnake outside you're gonna you're
gonna [ __ ] me away from that thing
however you can that's exactly how this
is how i learned a moonwalk now i had
michael jackson wallpaper uh but my
favorite was actually walk the line
i loved joaquin phoenix's performance it
touched me it moved me the fact that
june carter was so un you know involved
and and you know the fact you look back
and you reese witherspoon won an oscar
for that and joaquin phoenix didn't win
for that like i don't remember who won
that year but it must have been stiff
competition because that to me that one
just
there's only one joaquin he's so good
he's so good it was so deep it was one
of those it was kind of the equivalent
of this like i think rami malek was born
to play freddie mercury and i think he
was born to do that role yeah walk the
line another uh super fresh film in the
tomato meter selena which we've covered
on this show um previously a great
musical biopic it just and and you talk
about a film that's introducing an
artist to
new generations to a broader spectrum in
the world selena has achieved that in
the years since it's been released and
rey is another one that i just felt like
jamie foxx which is so transcendental as
ray charles that if i can't say eddie
and the cruisers is a biopic story
because it's not actually based on
anyone then i'm gonna have to give it to
either ray or you know the other one is
love and mercy though if you all have
not seen love and mercy it's 89 percent
of the tomato meter and it's about brian
wilson and the beach boys and you have a
younger brian wilson played by paul dano
and older brian wilson played by john
cusack and it's just it's a very well
told story with again probably some
shoulder relaxing of the facts but come
on at the end of the day we are there
because we're fans of the band and the
achievement that i can get bohemian
rhapsody above everything else is that
it did remind me how big of a queen fan
i truly am favorite queen song sharonda
are you going with the classic we will
rock you into uh we are the champions do
you have a queen tune that is going to
pop up on the old phone more often than
not my personal favorite that i like to
perform in the mirror is another one
bites the dust it is just that just
gives me the energy the confidence that
i need i i love that sound that's one of
my favorites all right so now we have
two tick tock vids that are going to be
in coming from sharonda we got her
performing another one bites the dust
and
she's in the gym all the time now kids
she's going to be moonwalking within a
couple weeks
we'll have a moonwalk off
we'll have a side by side if we like i
love this idea for all of us producing
lucy and engineer brian's got to get in
there too and then we'll just surprise
jacqueline next time she uh she rejoins
the show uh miss novak your favorite
queen song if you had to narrow it down
to one can i say under pressure with
david bowie and freddie mercury yeah
give me that lucy's given me the mic
drop on that one that song no matter
when it comes on where it comes on it
ends up being on a loop
and i just keep playing it over and over
it was so great when the oscars opened
with queen because i love a good opening
monologue at the oscars i love a nice
song and dance number but just to hear
the drum beat of boom boom
and everybody's just rocking in there
that's how you open a show like the
oscars but my favorite queen song is
going to be revealed in just a minute
first we bring brac producing lucy who
loves queen your favorite queen tune and
lucy you can actually sing a couple of
these ooh
actually i was in a band in college
called the cat's meow
and we got disqualified because they
asked me to get off the stage because we
went over time and i was like no f you
guys and i stayed up there to finish
somebody to love
that's the song that disqualified us i
love singing that song bohemian rhapsody
is a very nostalgic one for me just
because of our family road trips
but somebody to love and under pressure
i have to say in terms of like singing
and just like when i'm in the shower
i pretend i'm all the people singing it
and i'm just i go hard it's like i'm
rocking out man those those two songs
oh
that you could put a couple uh back in
back in my day in high school you put
together a couple great mix cds of all
time awesome queen songs my favorite one
just because i like my rock and roll
down dirty sexy and just a little bit
rule bending is tie your mother down
it's just about hey just just tell your
mom and dad something else because
you're sneaking out and you're going out
with me tonight i love that tune and i
also love that you can go on youtube and
when you're done watching live aid
nobody can ever match freddie mercury
for my money he's actually the greatest
lead singer that ever lived i think he's
the best rock league singer of all time
but queen continued to thrive after
freddy pass they took a few years off
but then they really reformed well in
the in the 2000s touring with paul
rogers who's the lead singer from bad
company that's some great stuff to
youtube but now obviously then with adam
lambert um it's just it's a really great
story that the band has been able to
cobble together since the passing of
freddie mercury and so we didn't cover
that in the movie but as brian uh brian
may joked in one of the interviews he
said well maybe we'll cover that stuff
in the sequel so that is gonna do it for
our movie talk here about bohemian
rhapsody quite the divisive movie quite
the interesting conversation here and
now we're gonna throw it over to mailbag
brian hit the music
[Music]
our mailbag this week is from esteemed
ketchup crew member alicia dixon you can
be like alicia any time you want to
email us rt is wrong
rottentomatoes.com let us know your
thoughts about movies that we've already
covered or what movie should we be
talking about and that's what alicia is
here to steer us towards she says dear
mark and nikki and sharonda inspired by
the cats episode i cannot believe i
haven't thought to ask you about this
absolutely bonkers movie it's so bad
that i've made people sit down and watch
it just to have lived that experience at
least four different times i find it
hard to believe that this movie got made
at all much less with people like mila
kunis sean bean and eddie redmayne
jupiter ascending is an absolute acid
trip of a movie it's sitting at 28
rotten 38 audience score and that is
generous however given the joy draw from
forcing people to watch this absolute
travis eva film i think it could be a
cult movie material one day and i'd love
to hear your thoughts about it thanks
alicia thank you for your email lisa
that's our first jupiter ascending email
that we've done on the show here
sharonda nikki did rotten tomatoes get
jupiter ascending wrong or is that 28
right on the money i haven't seen it
this movie is so good why does everyone
hate this movie
oh my gosh
all right i don't know what nikki and
sharonda were planning to do this
weekend but clear your schedules we're
gonna go to alicia's place and she's
gonna get to enjoy jupiter or sending
the way that she likes it which is just
making everybody else watch the movie
she can make me watch it is a travesty
nikki check that one out and get back to
us and sharonda
keep your phone handy because when we do
jupiter ascending we might need you to
come on back but in the meantime it's
just been so great catching up with with
two of my buds and we you know the three
of us we we've done a lot of stuff
during the pandemic together via zoom
and all that stuff and then sharon
getting to hang out with you on stage at
south by southwest it feels like a
million years ago it's only a couple
years ago and we had such a great time
doing it and and nikki it's always a
pleasure to see you so
sharon to start with you where can all
the kids out there find what you're
working on with uh with payor weight
anything else you want to tout as we say
good night here you can find some fun
reviews lives recaps i have it all at
payorweight.com or on my youtube channel
of the social media platforms at pear
weight
that is sharonda williams and nikki
novak what sort of new stuff do you have
in the hopper for us
i am
to be found at all things fandango and
rotten tomatoes you can't get rid of me
you guys
i'm going to be doing a lot of fun
junkets actually coming up we're doing
uh finally some in-person stuff i'm
excited about for some big movies that
are coming out in man june and july i
don't even think i'm allowed to talk
about them yet but yeah like you said on
morning shows quite a bit at nicki novak
on my socials and at sharonda's house
this weekend practicing my moonwalk
y'all just get giving y'all's work work
schedules you have to get up insanely
early in the morning so it's just a a
privilege that you managed to spare an
hour to come hang out with me so for
sharonda williams nikki novak producey
lucy our engineer brian perez and
jacqueline coley who is off on a beach
somewhere i am merely mark ellis saying
thanks for tuning in to this bohemian
rhapsody edition of rotten tomatoes is
wrong and we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you